pues el gobierno de manuel marco ha
pedido que se adapte aún más el derecho
francés para proteger a los menores tres
puntos muy importantes de que contiene
este proyecto de ley el primero la
prohibición de relaciones sexuales entre
un adulto y un menor de 15 años de hecho
en caso de acceso carnal pues será
considerado y automáticamente como una
violación algo que cambiaría lo que es
hoy pues la víctima tiene que entrar a
demostrar que se trata de una violación
que ella no había consentido a este tipo
de actos otro de los puntos es que se
refuerce el castigo o las penas digamos
cuando se trate de incesto
de hecho el incesto por ahora es
considerado en el derecho francés como
un agravante cuando se trata de algún
tipo de violación o de agresión sexual
pero según este texto de ley pues estas
relaciones incestuosas quedarían
prohibidas entre un adulto y un menor
esta vez de 18 años una crimen y con
esto pues el incesto pasaría a ser un
crimen incluso pues se tendría una pena
de hasta 30 años de cárcel y el tercer
punto es uno que seguramente pues va a
ser muy debatido porque es un gran punto
de discordia tiene
con la prescripción de los crímenes
sexuales hasta ahora la ley en francia
pues se dicta que estos crímenes
prescriben 30 años después de que la
víctima cumpla 18 años algo que las
asociaciones no quieren esperábamos que
haya tal vez o algo un cambio allí
cuando se trate por ejemplo de un mismo
autor que haya cometido estos delitos
indiferentes con diferentes víctimas
natalia gracias por la información